what is your wish for archie and lilitha
to grow up in a better world
i could not love and respect him more
he's the founder of the invictus games
and the father to our two little ones
archie and lily prince harry the duke of
sussex
with courage
you can overcome
anything
megan paid tribute to diana wearing this
white top almost identical to the one
the princess of wales wore during her
last portrait sitting megan also wore
this cartier watch just like the one her
late mother-in-law used to wear harry
and megan held hands and hugged athletes
but before the games got underway the
couple made a secret pit stop to windsor
castle royal expert katie nichol tells
e.t the couple met for about 15 minutes
with charles and camilla and then the
queen i've spoken to a source close to
the prince of wales who said that while
it was slightly tense it was also very
lovely for the prince of wales to see
his son he hasn't seen him for over a
year and the feeling is that this has
almost been a bit of an icebreaker the
sussexes are being tested at the moment
we've heard little bits about that
meeting with his father but nothing as
of yet about what happened with the
queen and i think this is because the
sussexes know that they need to really
keep this water tight you'd think that
harry's visit to windsor would be the
perfect chance to heal that royal rift
with his big brother william but will
and kate were away skiing in the french
alps i think what was made clear was
that when harry's trip was confirmed and
it was all going ahead william wasn't
going to change his own holiday plans
harry i'm told suggested perhaps that
they might get some sort of a mediator
in on these talks to make some progress
william and kade meanwhile led the
royals at easter services yesterday
queen elizabeth who turns 96 on thursday
did not attend but there was an adorable
easter first they took george and
charlotte to the easter sunday service
and i think we will see more of that the
cambridges are now here to step up to
the plate and to support charles and
camilla really now standing in for the
queen
[Music]